i understand that you're into something
called primal astrology yeah
my friends pete and patty uh put me on
to this a long time ago
and um basically like they take
eastern astrology and western astrology
the 12 and 12 and then they have on they
combine it to make 144
permutations and so then it gets more
specific
but really what it is for me is just
something fun and a way to judge my
friends
and then determine whether i should
still be friends with so
[Laughter]
this sounds useful and cruel uh so
you're able to figure out like there
might be someone who you're interested
in being friends with
and you can you can figure out their
yeah you like you like casually i was
like hey what's your birthday
and then you know they usually say like
april 5th i'm like no your full birthday
you're asking for the year because you
need the year and then when you get the
year
and you give them you do the whole
birthday you find out that they're like
a tarantula or something you're like
no i'm not i'm not going to be friends
with you anymore yeah that's in my head
but usually you know
what did you find out about yourself
what are you i'm a camel
so you are you can retain water for a
great period of time
i mean kind of like basically i think a
camel the good
the benefit is that i'm extremely lucky
which i'll vouch for i'm
extremely lucky um and the bad part is
is i'm also extremely naive because i'm
extremely lucky
and that checks out what what do you
what would you say is how is your luck
manifested itself parking spots
um really you you just always find a
good parking anywhere
i found one now i mean the guy led me
into it and he said it was the reserve
for me but like yeah that was not a
that was reserved parking for the guests
on our show
here's here's an interesting story um
this shout out to vanessa lanier
who at grossman jack talon in chicago i
had just moved to chicago
and um i'd been kept being told but
being told by you know my friends that
are like there's no way you can get an
agent there's no way that you can get
into this business that easy you have to
be here for several years and break your
teeth
and so i was prepared for that and i
went to this um
agents panel discussion at second city
and they were all on stage talking about
like how you need like a
doctor's head shot with like a
stethoscope
lab coat all that stuff and you know i
was sitting there like okay
taking all this in and then the panel
was over
and um they turned off the stage lights
and then everybody started rushing the
stage to give
these agents their headshots and resumes
and so i was like oh i'm not going to
get in past this crowd like what am i
going to do so i stayed back
and just kind of sat in my seat and then
they brought the house lights up
and one of the house lights the first
one went right over my head
and vanessa lanier she points over it
and goes like you
wait right there and she walked through
the crowd and grabbed my headshot and
resume and she's like i'll call you
tomorrow
so it's just you just pure luck yes and
it's also
i i mean sounds like a great agent but
to be tricked by
that one that the lights on you know you
know what i mean
i mean that's you've just so many people
are going to set up their lighting when
they go to something like that and then
click could have been anyone but that's
that's what i'm saying like
parking spots um being lit at the right
time yeah
road to a hollywood career like yeah
can't complain yeah but very naive um
and what would mine be
have you someone told me that you did
some research into yeah
yours is a llama right a llama yeah what
is a llama's qualities
i don't i didn't actually get into it
because i judge you just from here
without having to look at i don't like
being i wanted to be like a lion
wait what what's uh what's up does
anybody know what a llama is calling
andy what's a llama's qualities that
whenever you go
to a llama farm they say careful they'll
spit at you
so that might you know that i get that a
lot
also can i just say when you go to a
petting zoo no one cares about the llama
yes they do no they don't of course they
do they're so soft and sweet
but they will spit at you they might
spit at you yeah
you could have lied and said um you know
a tiger
a falcon a falcon a leopard
you know what i mean yeah well my my
house is
a camel my youngest daughter is a wombat
my older son is a ocelot
and my wife is a tasmanian devil
you